Leonard Leonard Leonard who is the girl  [Music]  I'm here to find a great lake a  freshwater and you seem to know a lot  about the desert so I like you to join  me  rola I've been up here a long time I've  never seen any traces of any lake I  think I've missed I missed you too soon  can I ask you a question that was a  question  what there's somebody else hi this is  dr. ooh it's bad I was trying to protect  you I don't think you need to do that  okay maybe we could protect each other I  just  Susan said we're closed for all we know  there's the lake you just be over the  next hill  is closed so crystal is closed so  crystal is cool you just keep walking in  the same direction better than walking  in circles  [Music]